[Music]
all right let's go donate this stuff to
let go that stuff get out of my life now
you don't spark joy all right we have
literally ransacked our closets for the
past couple of weekends it is some
tiring stuff trying to clean out your
house and all this cleaning attic
laundry right now once again we are
partnered up with DiGiorno it is not
delivery its DiGiorno today we got that
cheese stuffed crust pizza we haven't
tried the juice yeah I was telling them
we haven't tried this one yes I'm really
excited about the cheese stuffed crust
[Music]
Isaac pizza time and I'm so glad I only
finished this project but it was just
our closets like we still need to
convert the rest of our home which is
like the kitchen and like all the river
birds like the linen closet and the
office we haven't done that
in order it was like it feels like we're
moving houses without moving houses yeah
but it's gonna be easy once we do move
houses eventually whenever life does
happen and we've already like shed all
the things we don't want man it was so
crazy for me to really see that huge
like on the first date let's see that
humongous pile of clothes on the back
this is so crazy
that's not even counting all the dirty
clothes that I have in the Hat but right
now I did not know I own this much yeah
that's like it's almost embarrassing
that's crazy
I put everything that I own except like
underwear stuff and bathing suit stuff
and accessories like scarves and gloves
and stuff I didn't put that in here but
everything else is there and I'm out of
breath oh my god I show Casey this this
is crazy oh that's so crazy that lets it
go really fun like take a jump on two
though no the hangers will kill you got
you must do mind you when you're mine
where would it fit it'll touch the
ceiling no way make it touch the ceiling
everyone are you gonna start discarding
discard pile yeah asking if it brings
you joy and all that kind of stuff yeah
I already as always pulling things out
there were already a ton of stuff that
I'm like oh I don't want this I already
know what I want to get rid of you want
to bet that you're gonna be able to get
right half of it
I think more hopefully more hopefully
more than half this is a lot and plus a
lot of it's like old wardrobe and you
know how we film a lot we have to
continuously get new wardrobe this is
gonna be my excuse to go shopping
somewhere look at all these junk I have
like hey these are all the accessories I
was talking talking about like scarves
and then in here it's all more scarves
and beanies and gloves and like winter
stuff so I'm not touching that yet and
then here it's like old socks I don't
even know why I keep these like I would
never use them ah there's like so much I
need to get rid of thanks so much
so much there's just so much you know
what also doesn't help is that when we
go to events I'll come back but a whole
bunch of free stuff which I love free
stuff but then I feel guilty if I don't
use it and I throw it away then I just
feel really wasteful so I ended up
keeping everything and I know Cheerios
are thinking why don't you just give it
away to your friends and stuff and I do
think of that and I and then I'll put
the things away like I'll set them aside
for particular people and then I just
never get around to giving it to them
like for example my cousin Jenny that
lives in Orlando I have so many things
I've saved for her and I keep telling
her to like I need a ship over this box
to you I have been it's been sitting in
my closet for like years and I just
haven't given her the stuff that I want
to give her but now is the time I just
gotta I just got a con worried the crap
out of my life
[Music]
okay it's been exactly three hours like
literally on the dot three hours this is
how long it took me to do all of this
oh here's the keep pile it's just all
thrown up there and then over there it's
like my wedding dress and stuff I could
not get rid of that I just couldn't in
Sparks too much joy for me well it's
under here this black thing is my
wedding stuff yeah all of this is keep
this is to go away this is everything
that I'm gonna be giving away Jane like
I built a wall of clothes I'm pretty
proud of myself though some items were
really hard to get rid of because like
you know you go through things in life
and like like for example the outfit I
was wearing when we got engaged I was
like but it doesn't like I don't want to
wear that outfit anymore so I'm like
what's the point of keeping it just for
sentimental reasons I don't get happy
when I see it even though it's a nice
memory but the item itself doesn't make
me want to use it so I'm like okay well
what's the point of that I am keeping my
wedding stuff though because just
knowing that I have it in my possession
does spark joy so I can't get rid of
those things but everything else in here
I'm like man's there were some things
that I've kept since before Isaac was
born I succeed eleven years old like
that stuff is old
um but yeah like over the years I just
never got rid of it and now I'm like
okay thank you for everything you've
done for me
item of clothing but now it's time to
let you go so yeah that it's been really
therapeutic now I know why everyone
who's done this like they just say like
you know you just end up feeling like a
weight has been lifted off your
shoulders and I definitely do feel that
because I have been dreaming of doing
this or like months like literally
months even before
the Marie Kondo even before the Marie
Kondo special thing the TV show on
Netflix even before that came out I have
been dying to go through everything and
just like purge everything I don't want
I finally did it
and it's only step one can you guess
which ones to keep which ones to get rid
of that's a good question that's to get
rid of why there's more over there yeah
yeah that's all you're gonna say goodbye
to all this stuff yep this morning no I
don't pull anything out it's like a wall
of clothes it's gonna come criminally
now I can't wear the robe - yeah I don't
wear that robe anymore
sure I never see where that's one of my
first clothing gives to you was it yeah
you know one of her roles is to not let
your family members see you the things
are getting rid of because of this exact
reason just did or trippy - yes this is
literally what she says in her book
do not let your family see the things
are getting rid of I did
all right I finished singing everything
back up it looks exactly the same
because I spread everything out but I'm
gonna compress everything and then show
you guys how much I really did get rid
of all right
so I pressed all my clothes together
like I just compressed everything just
how it was before cuz before I could
barely like move anything to just try to
fit something in between but now look
half of the closet is gone I really did
it guys I got rid of all all this is
clear so now there's way more space for
all this stuff to kind of be spread out
and my clothes can breathe not bad
it would be a lot less if I actually
decided to do the entire folding thing
but like I said I'm skipping that I have
a ton of room to just hang everything so
I must stick to hanging when we first
started the Marie Kondo process we do I
don't know about you but I thought it
was gonna be like oh yeah I can spare a
couple of hours cleaning out the closet
and stuff but one weekend per person so
it was like one weekend for me to get
everything done remember we can one day
and then one
you take all your clothes and stuff done
and then one day to get Isaac stuff done
so ugly and I'm just like oh and to
still have to do everything else yeah
and actually like keep our lives going
yeah it was pretty uh yeah you want to
sleep on that yep
okay cool make my work today is done
because Isaac wants to sleep on it
tonight all right Isaac finished going
through all of this clothes this is all
the stuff to get rid of this is all the
stuff he's keeping now we just gotta
organize it how do you feel baby yeah
yeah you know all that junk in your I
was gonna say in your trunk but in your
closet yeah now we got to go through all
of your toys you have a lot of toys you
gotta sort through in this closet here
there's just the whole bunch of toys
you're like I've had enough you've been
going for hours and hours and I think
we're coming to an end for the day and
we've made just a little bit of a dent
in the entire house we did a lot at that
I was saying earlier if this box this
was worth the price of what we got these
items for this would be a lot of money
and then what did I say right actually
that that's why people are hoarders
because they don't want to throw away
that value yep exactly these little
hangers I'm like oh yeah I don't want to
get rid of them
no baby hangers
it's nice difference yeah cuz I'm like
it's probably gonna be using them I hope
probably using them soon doesn't it feel
better know that you don't have nothing
you don't have all that stuff in your
closet yeah now you're like oh finally I
have clean closet open it okay since I
was a person who cleared out my closet a
few weeks ago I have now had to pretty
much deal with the fact that I don't
have as many clothes as I have used to
have before meaning like now for
wardrobe and like for take apart because
every time we filmed a gay party we need
to bring like six or seven outfits and
if ridicu news is just one outfit but
it's once a week so it's a lot of
different outfits and now I feel myself
repeating the outfits over and over and
over again so it feels like I have very
little wardrobe to wear now whenever we
film so I'm like dang I need to go
shopping
Oh Avery another thing which just makes
queues to go shopping no but I'm saying
like I actually hate shopping but it's
just a mess that a necessity because of
the fact that we film so much like we do
need it or I have wardrobe and it is a
tax write-off so that's kind of nice
tonight
but yeah like I don't know I just I
don't want to do that I wish I could
just hire someone to do it because the
actual shopping process is just so like
is your knee dropping - that's true and
I make you [ __ ] pikelets whenever we find
yourselves in the mall
I don't know yeah really what kind of
pizza long enough and you're like and
that looks really good I like that you
just look really kissable so yeah so we
gotta buy stuff you're so sweet it
tastes like a mozzarella stick this is
like mozzarella stick and a pizza and
this cheese it tastes like the cheese it
tastes so fresh and like light
[Music]
[Music]